hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
it's John over here so there's this
extended TV spot one way is calling a
thunder another way is calling it
Steppenwolf speaks according to em dooba
oh boy and several people have set this
our way and we've seen a bunch of TV
spots and trailers we thought we were
done for the next couple weeks but hey
if Steppenwolf speaks it would be cool
to hear that man's voice knowing the way
how Justice League says with stuff like
mirror fights parademons probably be
like a split second oh yeah he's gonna
say hey
[Music]
there was
[Music]
like this trinket
[Music]
just have to save it sure as hell we're
gonna avenge it I read a so I don't know
if I ever thought a TV spot we don't
have we the line about we just have to
save it or I read it on someone's
Instagram post I don't know why I'm
pointing that all right to the first
part of that line I was like I know the
rest of his life yeah yeah it's kind of
predictable lying - actually that's true
hey hey where is that line where
Steppenwolf speaks oh when he's holding
up that dude and he's talking about
family cuz they all have the same ones
the cool part about this image though
when he when he does say it is you can
tell his mask is off it's just a profile
shot so justice Lee doesn't want you to
see Superman and they don't want you to
see Steppenwolf without his mask on in
the trailers in the marketing and I mean
this actor was really cool played Mance
Rayder in Game of Thrones a lot of lot
of movies I don't pronounce his name
Sharan Hinds hands hearing nicest Irish
guy he's a damn good actor the costume
I'm kind of a little little worried
it looks very CG I mean I like I say is
a little worried about about you have to
just hit a little bit of sentence and
then BAM DC fans dislike the crap out of
your video pacifically it's all right
it's all engagement a lot and mash any
and every button a bunch of letters
I'm kind of wondering the suit if you
actually see his face underneath this
suit it could look really cheesy his
suits so CGI then you got a human face
to it in wait a minute so that's not his
face and this isn't just like a helmet
surrounding his face yeah I know it is
gonna be all CGI this is like mocap or
something she's just a profile though oh
yeah could not be but the CGI
answer to me from here here's what I'm
thinking now
uh-huh right now I've said it a billion
times say one last time mm-hmm all I
want for this is to be an entertaining
film
I feel like this film is gonna be cheesy
sure oh I'll meet you there
I feel like it's gonna be cheesy I think
so too and that's not a bad thing I
don't think it's gonna be Batman and
Robin cheesy Zack Snyder put something
together Joss Whedon changed at least
30% of it amped up some fun made it a
little more cheesy I just don't know I
feel like this is gonna be cheesy the
way that your friend who made the last
party really dark and awkward tries to
be like really upbeat the next day and
like ignored the weirdness from the last
time you saw them like that's the kind
of cheesy I imagined yeah cuz I feel
like this should have epic emotional
scale which I don't think it's gonna
hand out I just feel like it's gonna be
cool cheesy fun and a bunch of bros
kicking it with Wonder Woman in terms of
all of the different ads and trailers
and TV spots we've seen for this I mean
this is a cool trailer in and of itself
I mean I like to at least showed us a
couple different shots looked a little
bit different and it bothered to give
everybody a title card and a few shots
from there yeah I'm excited the story
and Aquaman taking a shot of water at
the bar okay I know it's probably Apple
I don't know how to feel about Aquaman
now because I feel like they've gone
like there's such a thing in comic book
culture about Aquaman being a sort of a
dweeby character and then when they
rebooted Aquaman one of the first things
they did at least in the new 52 was be
self-aware and acknowledge that people
think Aquaman is lame even though he's
not now in this movie he's just coolest
dude of all time oh no in this movie
he's Jason Momoa he's what we think of
Jason which you know up until those
recent comments was just like what a
cool dude don't actually Jason Momoa
interviews I'm like yeah it seems like
Aquaman right here yeah it seems like
they had him show up and do his thing
well that's the thing about when Jason
Momoa auditions though he doesn't try to
necessarily do what the comic book is
like he auditioned for Batman and he
made it his very own audition really
yeah cuz he's like look at me I don't
look like Bruce Wayne I have long
built like this you know so so he kind
of did his own weird thing with it so I
feel like that probably might might have
worked for Aquaman when he did that you
know do I give it a new edge it doesn't
matter John we already spent our money
on tickets we're already going there
they've already brought people are
thinking this will be a box office flop
you know this is the first time in a
while where I am very much wondering
because you know holding on to the
reviews is a signal regardless Wonder
Woman's in it though yeah I feel like
this'll do all right I feel like it'll
do all right I don't know if it'll
necessarily do the kind of like
record-breaking business that some of
the pre asks you know I've used I feel
like people will call it a flop in the
way how they call bbes a flop it made
close to 900 million dollars but it
didn't do better than the Dark Knight or
The Dark Knight Rises two people were
like it's the missing percentages there
are just in the quality of filmmaking
really I have you've made 900 million
plus dollars you're doing I think
they're holding off interviews too
because of thor ragnarok coming out so
close to it thor ragnarok comes out two
weeks before yeah I don't know I mean
John if the review is the benefit of if
they were in this movie what they need
to do that oh you just ask the tough
questions don't you Frost
it's gonna be great it's gonna be so
much fun you guys nothing to be worried
about I should have just kept Superman
with the mustache that would have been
interesting I'll be like in the grave he
grew a moustache a moustache and that's
how we know his character has grown a
moustache right click that notification
Bell find us at patreon.com slash the
real rejects and also check out the
Stardust app start us after downloaded
follow us a lot of your favorite
youtubers like John Flickinger flick
pick whatever the hell was real last
name is I'm pretty sure it's Flickinger
not 14 Jeremy Jones and the schmoes and
cleric wolf lates the Labour Party a lot
of people are using it right now and
we're on it too but if this is your
first time hearing about that app follow
us first and download it in this special
unique you
because they need to know it was us it's
the way these things were reception